if you don't know about this like I said
I do not trust you at all my favorite
games on here is probably midnight club
b boy jackass Rainbow Six Siege Socom
but Midnight Club especially I got to
talk about midnight club if you know
about that game especially the
soundtrack of that game I grew up on
these this is probably like my seventh
PSP I used to break these all the time a
little bit last year I was just playing
my PSP before the shows it was very like
common roasting each other is a very big
part of like Xbox culture and if you
know about them them game chats you know
how we could get we not even going to
talk about that on here yall can do your
own researches for that roasting people
through Ramen was just another Outlet of
just flaming them like just had to Flame
them and I'm like oh I could
probably do this on Beats too so I found
this app on the app store called band
lab started downloading YouTube beats
put it up in band lab Apple headphones
behind the pop filter going crazy